entrance to the paintball court costs
five dollars and paintballs are paid for
separately a ticket for entrance with
five balls for example costs eight
dollars so let's define some variables
here let's let
let's let p
equal the price that i'm paying for
admission and the balls and let's let b
equal the number of balls
number of balls and we know that the
price is going to be a function of the
number of balls we can make a little
table here so let's make a table
where for a given number of balls let's
figure out what the price is going to be
so let's just start at zero balls if we
have zero balls we have to pay just to
get into the paintball court and that
costs us five dollars
now they tell us a ticket for entrance
with five balls so now we have entrance
and five balls this is going to cost
eight dollars
and they tell so let's think about what
the incremental price per ball here and
we're going to assume that the price per
ball is constant after you pay for
admissions after you pay this first five
dollars what's the price per ball
well when our number of balls increase
by five
our price increases by three dollars by
three dollars so plus three so we could
say our change in price
over the change in the number of balls
is equal to
our change in price is three dollars
when our change in the balls are five
dollars so this right over here this
could also you could view this as your
unit price per ball your unit rate of
change of price per ball this is going
to be 60 cents per ball 60 cents per
ball
so let's think about constructing an
equation that represents how much we
will pay as a function of balls
so we could write and we could write it
in function notation if we like we could
write price as a function of balls is
going to be equal to
well you're going to start off just
paying five dollars just for getting
into the place you're going to start off
getting five dollars and then you're
going to pay more depending on the
number of balls you get and you're going
to pay 60
60 cents per ball you see that right
over here when you got five balls you
paid three dollars three dollars for
five balls is the same thing as 60 cents
per ball so you're then going to pay
60 cents
60 cents per ball after that so this
right over here is the equation that
represents or that's a way of defining
price as a function of balls and we can
also try to graph it so let's do that
so let's actually try to graph it as
well
so let's that's our price axis our
vertical axis and let's say this is our
the number of balls axis
so this is balls and this is price as a
function as a function of balls so when
the balls are zero
when the balls are let me just in a
color i haven't used yet when the balls
are zero
the price we've already seen is five
the price and i'll make this this let's
say this is five this is 10
this is 15.
so when the when the when we have zero
balls we're going to pay five and then
when you see when we have five balls so
let's say this is five right over here
when you have five balls we paid eight
dollars which gets us right around here
and two points to find a line so this
function you could
is a linear function and it would look
something
something like this and if you ask what
is the slope of this line well the slope
is the rate of change of the vertical
axis with respect to the horizontal axis
so what is that so in the horizontal
axis and we've just frankly we've
already calculated this
when the horizontal axis changed by five
when your change in b is equal to five
your vertical axis
so your vertical axis
so your change in price was equal to
three so your change in price over your
change in the number of balls
which would be the change in the
vertical axis over the change in the
horizontal axis which is the definition
of slope it's a way of defining the
inclination of this line
that is going to be equal to 3 over 5.
over five
three over five which is exactly what we
calculated right over here just thinking
about it in a slightly different way now
we've thought about this in multiple
ways let's actually try to answer their
questions let's figure out which of
these actually apply so the first is
that the relationship is proportional so
if we had a proportional relationship
between the two this function would look
like this it would be p is equal to some
constant times the number of balls and
by definition in a proportional
relationship in a proportional
relationship when your number of balls
is zero your your price would be zero
and that's not the scenario we have here
when your balls are zero you're still
paying five dollars so this this is not
this is not a proportional relationship
next question the next statement
entrance with 10 balls costs 16 dollars
well we can test that out when b equals
10 so the price
for 10 balls is going to be equal to 5
plus 0.60 times 10. well this is 5 plus
6 which is equal to 11 not 10. so this
isn't right either
when the number of balls increases by 11
the price increases by
sixty 6.60
so remember the change in price over the
change in the number of balls is going
to be equal to let me get a right good
color here so let me write it here the
change in price over the change in the
number of balls is always going to be
equal to three-fifths
and so they say this is going
the number of balls increases by
11.
so three-fifths is equal to what
over 11. so let's think about that a
little bit
so three-fifths is equal to well let's
write it this way
three-fifths is the same thing as point
six so let me write this 0.6 is equal to
the price change over 11. i'll just
write that as a question mark as a
question mark over 11 you multiply both
sides by 11 you get 6.6 is equal to
question mark so this is absolutely true
the price increases by 6.60 when the
number of balls increases by 11. so this
one right over here is absolutely true
and then finally when the x-axis
represents the number of paintballs the
slope of the graph
of the relationship is five-thirds
well here we did represent the x-axis as
the number of paintballs or the
horizontal axis is the number of
paintballs but our slope wasn't five
thirds it was three-fifths so this last
statement is absolutely not right so
this is the only one that we can say
applies